well guys I mean I hate to tell you this
but you need to wake up I'm already
awake you got to wake up I'm already
awake go on obviously given there are
infinite possibilities of uh universes
out there and planets it's obvious that
aliens exist and specifically we have
them oh [__] we have them in our
possession in Area
51 um so yeah we as as we know there is
a highly classified US Air Force
facility in the center uh is the center
for research on aliens and UFOs and the
Extraterrestrial technology is being
reverse engineered there ooh yeah i'
I've been there not inside but would
I've been to the front of Area 51 Joey
Joey you know more about this you've
been to this place yeah they don't want
us to to know I I lost a uh I I lost a a
microphone head inside Area 51 after it
blew off my camera and went under the
rails and I was like I could go and get
it or I will get shot so all what what's
your proof Conor what's your proof yeah
what's your proof proof how do how do we
why do you think aliens would have
visited why here why are they kept in
Area 51 well it's a very you know
there's not much going on in Nevada well
true the real estate was very easy to
come by facts um so yeah I mean uh so I
have many reasons why I believe this go
uh you know obviously we've all seen
UFOs right
we obviously okay I mean we've all
watched The History Channel as well the
documentation aliens you always hear
about numerous reported sightings of
UFOs in the vicinity of Area 51 uh that
further increase my belief of the fact
that they're clearly that's like that's
a a hanging out spot that's where they
go yeah um why would all those people on
TV lie about seeing aliens why is there
so many documentaries about men uh and
women who have seen uh maybe because
people like
attention you know very very critical
like seen critical thinkers that you
know you see on television you know yeah
definitely yeah and you know obviously
the government who we don't trust uh
they it all comes back to the government
baby they would cover all they are
covering up all the evidence of alien
life and using era 51 to cover it up
okay why why why because we're not ready
we're not ready to know Humanity has we
aren't ready to know about aliens and
let's be real we'd probably just like
try and kill them or something or try
and steal their alien goods and use them
so the government is there in place and
espcially every1 to kind of have this
place to be like let's figure out what's
going on here you know let's study these
aliens cuz there's also notorious
crashes that have happened that are
unexplained we don't know anything about
okay um and where where did they all go
why are they hiding it from us
[__] okay okay okay you know and this
site is clearly being used to reverse
engineer this alien technology uh to
recreate it for themselves so that we
can then expand it to outter space
ourselves and take are they using it
only to expand to outer space we we
don't really know what the what the
malicious intent of the government is
but for some reason they don't want us
to know why they have aliens here right
right uh but we you know I think the
common belief is that aliens look like
these kind of bulbous weird ass things
and I think that's just wrong yeah the
little gray guys right yeah I think I
think that's that's you know maybe the
ones of Mexico sure that that that's but
they're Mexican aliens they're a bit
different you know obviously As We Know
all these very reputable people they
keep coming out who worked in the
government were like hey we have aliens
lots of interviews with people I mean my
favorite source of information The Joe
Rogan podcast had a had a had a ex
government employee worked at A51 who
attested that there was aliens at A51 oh
okay um and you know we have these
unexplained footages of these vehicles
that move back and forth super fast uh
in this sky that we can't explain uh why
they move like that cuz No Object we
know can move like that so why is that
aren't they called like uaps now instead
of UFOs unexplainable are they're trying
to they're trying to they're trying to
it's it's a new branding thing it's like
Lexus to Toyota yeah yeah they're trying
to distract us from the the fact that
it's a Toyota yeah um these are still
UFOs and they're trying to get like all
the crazies off of it but we're not
crazies we we know what we're talking
about M um and there's you know there's
loads of blowers that have come out
saying this and there's clearly there
underground facilities that aren't
visible to us under a if you want it's
it's just a landing strip okay like it's
just an air base yeah of course there's
too much room going on there you know
what I mean there's got to be something
underneath that they're hiding how busy
is that airport you know right really
you have this big of a site just for
airplanes to land that doesn't seem
right that's true so probably underneath
there is a whole facility for aliens all
right out here here's here's the big
thing here's my big
question why would you want to hide you
know let's say aliens did visit the
world what do you mean we're not ready
we're not ready what what maybe the
technology is so Advanced that we a
either don't have any kind of scientific
understanding of it or B maybe it's a
type of Technology where if it does come
out into the world then let's say you
know America is the first one to like
introduce it right what's going to stop
like you know uh any other country you
know whether they be friend or F of
America to be like hey we can use that
12 but we can make it better to go one
step above see that's exactly what they
thought about the moonlanding as well
you have to look at the greater you know
the greater goals of the government G I
feel like you're very short minded here
and you're not thinking about what the
government wants the government
specifically the US government wants to
control everything they want to have the
power and if they get their hands on
alien Tech first it's game over sure
what is you know what the hell is any
other who else is going to compete with
that if they got teleporters you know
they got some crazy be laser guns from
Cod they finally get those in real life
it's game over they said crazy beans I
was like what they might have alien
beans you know very convenient that they
landed in America you know like they out
of every uh place in the world they
convenient chose like one of the biggest
superpowers uh in the world uh and just
chose to crash land there and may aliens
were like yo this is what's up this a
big open space presumably if they landed
in another continent America would have
done their best to get a hold of it
anyway you know what I mean they're
pretty good at doing that they're pretty
good at taking things sure sure you know
and it just goes into you know we see
UFO spottings all over the world yeah
that are unexplained okay um hold on
let's let's let's put away the dash of
irony away for just a second do you
legitimately believe extraterrestrial
life exists out there yes they in are 51
J I just told
you okay because I I 100% believe it I
just don't believe they've come to Earth
yet that's what the US government wants
you to think J
yeah yeah they have them um it depends
on like what level of alien life you
believe I like this is like Area 51 like
I said cool concept cool cool thought
experiment about just like you know your
government just keeping secret
technology and secret aliens that had
visited 50 or so years ago convenient
that they chose like kind of like this
time period in the entire history of the
earth to come visit um a lot of things
need to no the aliens that were around
as well like during before like this
period as well they build the pyramids
yeah who build the pyramids well I
wouldn't go that far that's Easter
Island heads how do they get there well
there's a lot of there's potentially
other explanations but I'm I'm more
concerned about the fact that I know the
US government has these little Al been
to that restaurant a little alien that
looks awful yeah that's that's the one
next
to Area 51 I've been there yeah it was a
[__] hole no aliens either I mean
advertising I'll I'll be up and say say
that I believe if aliens did land I
think the government would just say it
because they've already released the
tapes of the uaps or whatever they're
called right nowadays yeah why did they
announce that why now yeah they they've
been hiding it for so long why now are
they suddenly like we admit it guys they
are here um yeah that's a that's a doozy
um there's a you know we we don't know
the th off or was that planned we don't
know the process behind how the
government makes the fact the fact is
that these videos just dropped and then
everyone just kind of like no one really
like talked about it or just like it
didn't it didn't cause as big of a fuss
as you'd think a government dropping
some videos being like hey we don't know
what the [__] these are we're not going
to say they're aliens but we just don't
know it's them saying hey aliens we're
not scared of you we got your we got
we've got the technology we've got your
Tech now you're done you're done kid
don't come back we'll tell people about
it like we're not worried now um so you
know I I think the Pentagon releasing
videos it's whatever you know this is
like don't worry about it they're just
trying to distract us from the real
thing of the aliens are at alien 51
right right it's okay because we still
have Jeff Goldblum and Will Smith
they're both still alive they are alive
Independence Day is coming anytime and
we have our sequel weapons guys Will
Smith and Jeff gold they're there
they're there bigger
Legend where they go head tohe to see
who can save the world wish there was
more I'm I'm done pedaling this Theory
now I wish there was more like to make
this this Theory more exciting I wish
there was actually like any kind of
circumstantial evidence that could be
like well that's just a you know yeah
one of the biggest things about the area
51 I just like I don't know where it
came from yeah people just start making
[__] up here here's the weird thing I
remember reading about this Roswell Area
51 story in like a book in like a random
book I got out of the library when I was
like a kid uh um and I like for the
longest time I just believed it like
genuinely I thought oh aliens were in
Area 51 cuz I read a book about it um
and I like it wasn't until I was older
that I realized oh this wasn't like any
booked based on any form of reality this
is just a really interesting story you
know that just got presented as kind of
like this half fiction half kind of like
yeah this is kind of an interesting one
because like you know there are there
there are conspiracy theor is like say
like you know the Flat Earth one where
like if you say that you believe in it
then immediately you'll get like a
backlash of people being like no you
you're stupid why would you think that
but this area 51 one is interesting
because even if you say like oh yeah I
think there are aliens in Area 51 there
almost like a lack of interest it's just
kind of like yeah I guess I think when
you say that everyone is kind of in more
of a like a jovial sense like yeah I
believe was aliens you know it's not
like I don't think if someone was
actually 100% Going to you and like seem
super serious about it I think you'd be
like what
the that's true that's true yeah but
like you know I think we don't know what
other life is out there I think this
genuinely like we we don't know like
there's the universe is so vast it
probably it probably will not take the
shape that we've envisioned it will yeah
um I think it'll if there is life out
there it might not be as intelligent it
might be way more intelligent we don't
know there's odds are there's probably
something somewhere in un I I think
what's I think what is weird is that the
government so you know UFOs UAP do exist
there are unexplained phenomenon in this
world and do we want to just blame
aliens or do we just blame aliens it's
it's it's very very convenient and very
very easy My Favorite theory about uh
aliens that I've heard uh is that aliens
have already visited us and have been
visiting us for a long time it's just
that the aliens live on a different
dimension to
ours so we can't perceive them well they
they're like fourth fifth sixth
Dimension aliens you never know the
average there could be one right here
but I would not be able to perceive it
ah the average Rick and Morty fan yeah
okay there's an Al in here Morty I mean
I mean I think I think the big thing for
me is just the concept of like what an
alien life form would be and how alien
life form would perceive us if they
discovered us as a species you know see
like as a science fiction fan I love
thinking about this kind of [__] because
it's like it just opens the room for so
different stories you could tell you
know and so many different like cool
like what if scenarios of like okay on
the day that it happens if it hasn't
happened yet how will we actually
respond what will they actually look
like how do they respond to us and we
respond to them like it's it's just a
cool Whata if scenario to think about
yeah I I like this Theory just because
there is fun a little more fun and chill
than the other ones I I I think it's
more fun and I think honestly out of
everything it's more believable as well
I can yeah I don't know there is so much
we do not understand what would you rate
this one then
uh like a five I very middle of the P
yeah five or like like like strong five
light six okay okay I'd say I'd go seven
wow seven know I'm saying seven because
this is the only theory that you know
we've had I guess the closest thing to
actual evidence that has been released
by a credible Source a credible Source
you know we've we've had maybe crazies
maybe not but people that claim they've
worked in the government that have said
hey these things actually exist yeah my
only problem with that is that a lot of
these dudes and just doing [__]
podcast circuits and making money and
doing appearances at conventions and
it's like well hold on now I think
there's I think there's an ulterior
motive here to why you're a
whistleblower and not just a guy who's
like hey I'm I'm retired I can make a
bit of extra cash and travel around if I
just talk mad [__] okay but to play
Devil's Advocate okay let's say you do
know that they exist yeah how do you go
about proving it I mean the the the
ultimate problem is that you can't yeah
exactly you can't you know we've we've
even seen it nowadays you know like even
if you had pictures or videos you're
automatically a whistleblower um people
would just assume that they're fake yeah
or you have an ulterior motive you know
yeah yeah it would be very very hard to
uh yeah it's it's I think in un the only
the like given someone that in that
position the only way you you'll get
your message out is by going on The Joe
Rogan podcast right that's probably the
best hope you can go for tell me
nobody's believing me but Joe
will I know Joe's got Joe's got my
back yeah I mean like I think the
biggest thing is just this idea that you
know think about think about our
technology right and think about how
long we've lasted we as like an
intelligent species in the entire
history of the Earth have lasted a
microscopic level
right and we are number one we are very
kind of like confident that we're just
one just not going to wipe ourselves out
you know that's like like thinking about
how long we've lasted compared to the
most optimistic of Our Kind definitely
yes compared to the [__] dinosaurs I
can't even conceptualize existing for
that amount of time and then one comment
just
goes whoop you're gone now you're
absolutely gone
there are so many believe there's alen
life out there but there are so many
different walls a society and a species
have to pass through to get to the point
one of them being the ice wall obviously
they have to pass through uh one of them
uh dealing with how how do you deal with
flat earthers you know and with the way
that technology is evolving okay this
this is going into some completely
different
topic with how technology is evolving
right now right do you genuinely believe
that humans as a species or as a society
would rather venture out into space or
would they just create a supercomputer
and just put their Consciousness into a
supercomputer which one do you think is
more likely well so you asking if
everything is a simulation more likely
or is as we'd expand and explore the
universe more likely I think I think
would would like if with with the way
you know humanity is going with the
direction that our species is going do
you think it's more likely that we would
want to if there would be more interest
in exploring the universe or creating a
kind of like Digital Universe in which
we can I think I think the answer to
that in my opinion is that the more
likely scenario is the supercomputer one
but the more correct answer is the
ventry to space that's the thing the
more like correct answer is yeah yeah
let's be explorers let's go into space
let's ensure like the survival survival
of the human race I know the average
[__] human they'd be like just give
me the [__] Matrix Man me we we
already play like [__] World of
Warcraft yeah yeah exactly exactly right
in a simulation you know I also think
this the exploring out of space is right
now is is not profitable and until it
becomes profitable or there's a like
countries have reasons to care about
trying to take over planets or anything
like that they won't we won't see a
giant push for exploring space I I think
there will be a huge profitability to it
yeah when but like right now the laws
most laws although not every country
sign up to it uh are you know space is
the property of mankind and no one
country should own like the moon or
anything like that yeah however I think
that stuff like that hey you never know
we might get to the point where like
every country has the necessary funds
and the technology and the science to
just like kind of start going out there
you know looking for stuff and then that
Galactic mortgage game going to be tight
you know it's going to get to the point
where it's like all right well Denmark
wants to buy EO uh for some reason but
um that's currently owned by America
right now so what are we going to do
there yeah I like I just it's it's going
to sound super weird but the survival of
humanity is not a big enough motivation
for humans to explore space the like the
people need to care about things on like
a personal level before we have't I mean
Collective interest into doing something
like you know what sucked when Humanity
had more of an interest in
nfts right before that [__] I think the
problem is with uh space exploration is
that it is a it is a decade long decades
long sorry commitment to to even get
anything done you know we saw the the
James uh Hub uh jameses James web
telescope that was like a huge
undertaking very expensive but for like
countries to get involved I mean we
can't even look like four years is ahead
we have to like worry about the next
election right so like the way the
system is current set up people only
care about what's happening right now I
think also people think just think I
think they just genuinely believe that
it's not going to happen in their
lifetime anyway they don't care people
don't care about [__] that's not going
to happen to them yeah so it's like if
I'm not going to experience it then why
should I care about it you know which is
cuz that's why I feel like a lot of the
generation right now they just don't
care about space exploration like a lot
of people just don't big problems to
worry about yeah they're like they're
like we shouldn't be spending money on
trying to send Rockets up when
I I can't even yeah I can't even buy a
[__] apartment or I can't even rent
an apartment to live in so why the [__]
is the government sending $2 billion a
year to send [__] rocks into space
yeah yeah it's un there's a there's a
lot of shortsightedness there as well I
think so there's a it's a a very nuanced
problem either way I'm need to go and
take a [__] so all right okay